this week on the true jory podcast the
strongest man on the planet
he deadlift at 500 kilograms he wound
will Strongest Man 2017 he's known as
the Beast and his name is Eddy Hall
that's exactly it he did his a fan and
he was jumping with joy all his team
would [__] one get him off selling
flowers we're going fireworks meet him
it was what you've just saw over a pit
stop
it's like a happy man yeah went from
literally one extreme to the other
yeah I was destined to be you know a
picture exactly I am NOT cystic you know
I bought in a way where I don't think of
better than everybody and than anybody
else but by thinking back there nobody
else's that's different
depression you know and I have to do
something for not do I have a dog to
stop me sitting in the house and
potentially slit my wrists
[Music]
so I'd be out different you're gonna
feel when I pulled that 500 outside it's
not funny
[__] the [__] I said you know what I
see in your eyes right here right now
what I was like I see me pulling 500
kilos and he just had the same body
language change like before competitions
I was like a caged lion yeah you know
you couldn't eat if you if you
interrupting my schedule if you made me
miss a meal or a training session or a
physio session you were [__] getting
your head Renzo something I've always
wanted to say yeah
today on the true Jolie podcast we have
the strongest man on the [__] planet
Wow
yeah Annie Hall thanks for coming it up
in hustling you for a while of them that
Hugh I've made no so it's good to be
here me you know I'll be like this is my
first ever podcast you know I just
thought the best of it I thought was the
best thing I say yeah but yeah I've
never had the time and I'll be totally
honest would never listen to your
podcast where I know what's daily
podcast Fame no it's not like
I'm used to this because when I first
ever message Eddie and this is delish it
was about 2012 a direct message serve
and I was like a big fun then even later
I've gone back a while and I was like
meh you got a need like tips far like
we're lifting anything like that and
obviously you must get that message a
[__] million times a day
yeah she's replied doing a push ups and
good but yeah actually that was I think
that was the year I looked watch a
documentary and I was I think that was
the year that you went to the world's
first time around yeah 2012 was my first
well strongest but yeah and now you've
worn it mmm
like the whole documentary that's how a
Netflix if anyone hasn't seen a corn
watcher eddie strongman it's all about
this pursuit of winning the world
Strongest Man title and the conclusion
that comes at the end of the movie is
like what if he does win it like will it
just be game all those idea is this the
end of Eddie because you just saw driven
now you've done it does it feel like
that ah it's it's very mixed mixed
feelings mixed emotions you know I've
always said to myself I've just got one
goal and that's to win the wheel
Strongest Man you know and that there's
nothing else on the planet I'd rather
have there's no other tile no other
accolade you know you could be the
fastest one on the planet the smartest
man but to me the most alpha male tile
out there is the world Strongest Man if
he if a bloke said that didn't want to
be the wheel Strongest Man then the
[__] line up their ass every man
wants to be the world Strongest Man and
that that's that's what you know that I
don't know why there's just maybe a
subconscious thing but that's something
I wanted I just had to have in my life
and I dedicated my life to it as you can
see in the documentary you know I went I
went all out and I've done a lot more
since
then you know r22 steps up and gone
above and beyond what people would
expect to do to achieve it you are you
are really underrated from the get-go in
my opinion cuz it's like no English lad
had done that well I mean Terry Collins
had got third I think but apart from him
it'd been a long time and people didn't
seem to believe in you the way you
believed in yourself and you've [__]
proved a lot of people wrong
how does it feel like when you got on
that why him and yes we lifted it above
your head what was that moment like well
that's exactly it's it's proving the
naysayers wrong and that's honestly what
fuels my fire you know what I I say
we're gonna win the UK Strongest Man
back in 2011 you know I probably Don
free competitions before that and I put
a status on facebook the week before say
I can't wait till in UK Strongest Man
next week yeah cocky arrogant that's
what I've always backed off my [__]
and that's the difference always backed
it off and then I suppose when people
say you're not gonna win the world
strong this man it hurts you know cuz
I've put my wife and soul into it so
honest to god there was those people
that had made me do those extra raps
for speed that little extra food did
that extra physio session access that
stretching session so not in a spiteful
I told you so sort of way but in a way
of I've proved you wrong you know you
can't do amazing things if you put your
mind and soul to something you can
achieve anything literally I'm living
proof of that
yeah I think there's something strikes
me about when you look at you as a
character you also when you look at what
should documentary I watched it again
last nights I thought I need a reminder
there's some quite emotional moments in
there there's something that most people
don't realize about the world Strongest
Man is actually quite a brave decision
to go down that path in the first place
it's like the same documentary squad
quite lonely you're alone for a lot of
the day it's an extreme on the body
which is something that if you climb a
mountain or you run marathons you
instantly see but people assume strength
and they think well he's only getting
stronger that's good for him but you're
pushing your strength to an extra degree
there's quite a lot of bravery did you
realise how much they were
you think at the beginning of your
journey you realized what it would take
to get to this point I mean I I
committed to becoming the world
Strongest Man when I was 19
you know I said you can ask anyone in
the local jail I said when I was 19 I'm
gonna win will strongest man one day and
pretty much to the day from the first
contest when I was 19 10 years later I
won the Wilshire buspar it took 10 years
of solid hard graft
and it is I couldn't if they described
it the worst way possible it still
wouldn't be enough to show what I've
been through you know it's the huge
sacrifices
it's from the age of 19 I've probably
missed God's honest truth ten training
sessions never miss a meal you know
stretching physio hot/cold treatments
you know even got to extremes of taking
loans out to buy himself a hyperbaric
you know a change bought endless amounts
of physio kit shockwave machines and
tens machines I have invested well over
six figures in my body well over you
know and and that's and that is that in
itself is a huge sacrifice because I'm
like every other guy you know what
mortgages to pay and I've got a wife and
kids to support and it put a massive
strain on me you know thought I mean the
wife you know man I've been with her
seven years and so we really really just
had a fish already thing ever you know
we had a holiday when we first got
together seven years ago and then it was
like every time we've mentioned holiday
are but there's this competition coming
up so I quite have a week off because
I'll you know I'm I might not win that
then because a week off takes you three
weeks to catch up nights out you never
do because you've got to eat at certain
times you've got a you know got to be in
bed in certain times
you know if I've literally missed every
parents evening for the kids school
plays birthdays have been away competing
or training even Christmas day you know
I've got to go and train you know how
happy I have to eat a certain time any
our birthdays or [__] Christmas is odd
but you know and I've nearly lost my
wife several times over it what I've
always said it's gonna be worth it one
day for that you know winning that
trophy and and it was you know all that
hard work and sacrifice and it you just
you know to me it was bullshitting
myself constantly it was this is for a
reason
and every time in the wife and I had an
argument about me you know go an hour
over the holiday it'd be but but just
wait till when the world Strongest Man
and it'll all get better you know I've
promised that every year for seven years
and then it's [__] happened you know
it's been it's been been worth it where
do you not have it we went to Mauritius
which is an Indian island in a [__]
fantastic did you go to you went to
Marissa's as the World's Strongest Man
what was this this was just after you on
it - yeah why literally two other things
last week or week before that so yeah
that was that was my of seven years with
seven years worth of holiday and the
honeymoon all in one said we are there
we went all life's a lot of a good time
yeah we had a we had a good [__]
holiday yeah that's fine literal
actually when I'm watching and I think
when I watch in the documentary I think
it's not just a documentary that lads
are gonna watch as well because you
really feel for your wife in there and
you see it from her point of view with
someone who's also sacrificing for your
dream and yet that pursuit of excellence
that you're on and just the everything
they're not important I've just got to
[__] get this dream and she is on
that just right next to you the whole
time when you do was she there with you
at the time or was she on the other end
of the phone when you tall though no is
the
the person I took out to well Strongest
Man with me was my physio hmm
so everything back home was all gone
through the internet you know Facebook
and update websites and wherever so yeah
and that in itself is tough as well was
but that wasn't through lack of you know
funding or whatever it was the fact she
wanted to come but it was I'm just so
[__] selfishly driven and it's like
you can't come babe because I've got to
look after year I'm gonna make sure
you're fed this is what I do and am i
I'm there for one reason and one reason
only
wind will strongest man and you see over
athletes taking the messages out taking
the mates out Center my there's it's
it's [__] idiot
it's stupid to missus work is that is
that something you saw or other athletes
doing them they went alone or do some
because you look up to a lot of the
other guys dozen of cake entourage is
over they another I mean for had took
like 30 guys they he's fluid main way to
start no problem buoyed by Weber style
he you know we stayed in his own flat we
all stayed in a hotel he stayed in his
own flat he brought in chef over Game of
Thrones money looking after oh man yeah
you know he went property very well end
of the day no no amount of entourage can
can be hard work
you know what I mean well since you've
brought them up actually it's probably a
good technical this because there was a
bit of controversy will Strongest Man it
was you know people saying he was
wrongly stripped of reps that he'd done
and then other people came back and said
well if he got that rep than any would
have done the barrels quicker why have I
done I mean yeah can you cover that a
little bit and explain what went down
and what your opinion is because he had
a run on Instagram after yeah I mean
first of all it was very bad
sportsmanship from four but regardless
in his head where he was don't over or
not you don't go on to social media and
slag your own sport off you know it's
really bad for the sport so but that's
one thing the second thing you know
you're up sparing this man when he won
your songs when I was the first man to
shake his hand and say well done and
that was not repeated to me it will
Strongest Man just connect us do you
give a [__] no I don't give a [__] but
it's a just shows what character for is
and it's disappointing for you it was
disappointing it was very hurtful
actually because you know you work you
had to deck off all year for a contest
you know me and four of our battles
before and we've been that close you
know we had a we had a contest at
Malaysia think 2014 where we came junk
first and he won on come back and I
still shook his hand in ticket like a
man
you're up strongest man he beat me by
one one or two points basically whoever
won that last event one and II beat me
you know and I took I'm not happy you
know but to be honest that that second
place that Europe's is what probably
gave me that last little bit of fire in
the belly that last month for training
for the world's it was like right [__]
you I'm gonna get you back for that
so I think that if a1 if I'd have won
Europe's maybe I wouldn't have won the
world's because I wouldn't have had the
same flyer yeah you know so something's
something's working your way but anyway
back today the controversy with for now
I can't go into too much detail you know
I'm in contract but find out Christmas
basically find out at Christmas yeah but
let's talk about it in a general way so
there was an event where you went out
and did X amount of reps
okay so for went out before me and did X
amount of reps I went out after I said
to all the referees the TV crew how many
reps do I have to do to win this event X
amount of reps I went out and dead X
amount of reps
hard I think nearly 20 seconds left on
the clock put the operators down and
walked away so that makes sense right so
and then after not before after I had
gone for then came out and said because
you've disallowed my one wrap and he's
not beat me but why didn't he say that
before or when yeah this is my this is
my major quarrel if they would give him
that extra wrap I would then have gone
out and gone how many reps do I have to
do now yeah I'll have done that will you
to use the twenty seconds that you had
used the twenty seconds to make sure I
would have done that it's complete I
don't know it's all these yes men around
for because I remember for walking back
into the tent after he did his event
very happy with this result very happy
you know he'd be everyone buy free wraps
on that certain event and you know it
wasn't till I went there he was unhappy
with how it went and that just seems to
me like oh I've been beat
oh that's try and [__] retract it you
know it was just [__] but I'm not
gonna say any more about it so I am in
contract but he will lose such a [__]
deck at Christmas and that's all I need
to say I don't need to say anything
because that all the facts will come out
you know people have been stipulating
and sane rates on a plane and all this
kind of [__] and that is just [__]
ludicrous you know the end of the day
the man got beat fair and [__] square
in a strongman contest and he can't take
it there's a lot of questions that come
off the back of that on there like when
you saw he came back in looking so
satisfied hmm what is that what does
that make you think well that's exactly
he did his event and he was jumping with
joy all his team with [__] wanking
him off selling
flowers were going fireworks meet him it
was what if that's all I'll be wrapping
stuff it's like you're happy mate yeah
it went from literally one extreme to
the other
yeah and that's why if we'd had done it
before I went out then fine you know III
perhaps would have given the gratitude
and the sad whatever if the referee said
yeah I'll give me that whatever adequate
out and done whatever I needed to do but
free referees watch the footage back on
fours
it's what's his words you know that the
discrepancy okay
all three wraps said it was genuine
he should have been disallowed Magnus
ver Magnusson an Icelandic himself said
he would have disallowed forward the rep
I've heard a lot of people were saying
afterwards that the one for me who
disallowed my world-record deadlift back
in 2000 always in you know so this you
can't say he's biased yeah you can't any
because he's [__] over before Brazil
like you took offense and and he got
criticized for that because he's he then
because of that Benny Magnussen one that
deadlift event yeah and I didn't so you
know he got criticized but I - I like a
man called him a prick then apologized
and then I shoot Benny's hand and I'll
just kick it on the head you know [__]
happens but to to just to just to bring
it all to public knowledge and try and
demean me was really bad sportsmanship
yeah sure there's something that I think
strikes you that I always watched world
Strongest Man as a kid and it never
struck me that you can always say
there's a little bit of compact Rick
[__] between you guys we all get on very
well I think what your documentary shows
is how close some of you guys are eating
lunch together those sort of things
that's not you don't see that on the
final product you can see quite a polish
thing I think the documentary shows that
quite well have you oh Sh you guys are
what's it like them when someone
Swagger's back in thinks he's all that
and then poses toys out of the pram does
that alienate him from the group at all
because you guys seem very close-knit
almost better 100
you know I think the feels for certain
strong men in the camp or the fields
everyone feels to say yeah you know I
mean yeah and as you can probably see on
some footage you know me and Brian get
along great
yeah and I'm massively respect Brian
here's here's the definition of a
professional athlete because I've never
seen someone as as professional as him
he takes everything so serious and to
the dart you know it doesn't sway
doesn't doesn't sway off track he
doesn't [__] about he gets [__] done and
he knows what he's doing and he uses
like me uses his resources you know he
pays someone five grand to do his diet
plan he does the hyperbaric treatments
and the hot keys got his own a hot cold
tub like myself and you know he invests
in himself and to be honest that's why
that's who I learnt that from when I
started seeing him spending $400 a week
on physio and $400 a week on food and
hyper but you know it decided either
spending like over a thousand dollars a
week on his own body a week and that
made me realize you've got to invest in
yourself and I'm pretty much freling
that kind of figures out myself you know
two hundred and fifty quid a week on
food two hundred and fifty quid a week
on physio I mean if I were to quit a
week just on those two things alone
that's a good [__] wage in the UK hmm
you know and then luckily I've got the
sponsors to pay for all this and that is
honest to god the only reason why I've
got two will strongest one state is
because I had the [__] back him and
why did I have the backing because I've
got the branding you know and that's a
big thing as well you've got a got a
showcase yourself and you've got to make
the sport entertaining I don't want to
be where there's boring [__] that walks
out doesn't left [__] goes back in
and pass himself on the back you know I
want to [__] be proud of my my
achievements and proud of Who I am and
that's the difference I think you're not
just a weight lifter MIT there's a hell
of a lot more to you that's for damn
sure
before the first second I started
watching the strongman it was like
honestly who the [__] is that a new
leader I say he's from 300 mm
straightaway they you stand out a male
and it the way yes screamer
that people just incidentally who's that
guy you're a small businessman you sort
of took from like that w/e wrestler sort
of mold embroidered at the strongman but
ironically just going back to the fact
that you know thoughts clear when he was
shafted if anything it would seem to me
that it would be in the interests of the
people who organized the event to make
the most famous celebrity in the event
the champion so why would they then give
it to the life from England do you know
I mean yeah it just you know just didn't
all I'd up to me and I'm sure when
everyone watches it Christmas still have
the same opinion his me you know he's
just but just literally a month is
literally furnished toys either brands
didn't go his own way and I let me say
one thing when I mean obviously you
might have heard the stuff that's going
on before and his personal life in the
minute which I'm not one to judge you
know I don't really give a [__] but the
fact that when he didn't get these reps
disallowed you should have seen the way
he was standing over the referees and
trying to get his own way and to misaki
[__] [__] you know which were you
using his size and presence to sort of
try and get them to change you know I
mean Colin brass was the head referee
and I could see him getting [__]
scared when all this was going on you
know he was quiet I think it was quite
worried he's gonna get banned on top of
the end of something you know which I
think in itself is wrong as well there
you go
what's it like having a room because all
of you think you're the Alpha or are the
alpha male in that room not many times
you get dynamic where there's so many
men in the room who will rate themselves
above the others do you ever see only
scrubs kicked off like nothing no I've
never seen any any tempers flown why sit
been in the game to be honest
you know I've heard the fights have
happened in the past you know and
tempers I've been erupted but that is
the alpha male in these men because that
is what they are they today they are
they are there to prove a presence you
know they're not there to make a number
of they're there to make the [__]
presence so it's a tough well they're
all nice guys you know and the
camaraderie is good but the end of the
day when that [__] whistle blows you
you want that guy to trip up and smash
his face and that's that's a truth
that's the truth we've all say the one
people say they wish and there are
people out there that will wish of our
athletes on yeah but they're the ones
that'll never win yeah you know rather
than ice guys the two night nice guys
always finish last and you are the bad
guy I'm the bad guy I'm happy being the
bad guy you know I don't care I'm out
I'm out for myself you know end of the
day when you're out there you're out I'm
not team you know I'm not a football
team I'm not I'm not paid millions and
millions of pounds to go and support
England and therefore Eddie Hall do you
prefer that you you're on your own and
it's just you and it so then you've got
an order blame if it almost hits then
it's it's on you yeah yeah pretty much
if anything goes [__] tits up it is
all on me I mean I've got a fantastic
management behind me who does all my
commercial stuff
and he's kept me out some some rather
good you know rather bad neither mmm-hmm
and he's sort of my mentor as well you
know he's in his fifties he's been there
done that made mistakes and made some
goodness it you know some good good
choices as well so I think I think I've
just been very lucky with my
surroundings as well as the branding
that I've done that I've just had that
said the perfect opportunity you know if
it didn't have the backing of they never
never met my manager I've never had the
money to buy
yeah the half of our chambers and that
the you know I've just I just had a
great journey very lucky great journey
how did you meet your manager so my my
manager now he is the local millionaire
basically you know it's very well known
in my in my town he's he's he owns water
world that I've heard a water world I've
heard of what work because that was the
one place everyone wanted to go when you
went on a school trip is if you live in
the Midlands it is one of the most
magical yeah so there you go so he owns
water well he owns it probably owns a
court or stoked to be honest you know
he's yeah and and and basically I joined
one of his gems and he has to see me and
we are to quit meeting I think he's
worried basically I was gonna come in
and destroy all his equipment so he had
he had me anything for that reason and
then you know saw safely no I mean
that's not the case you know he's got a
great you know like a sparse action you
know jacuzzi sauna cold pools and all
that so I joined for that you know to
use the swimming pool and everything and
he basically said all what the [__] you
doing here you know and I said that he
says well why you know what's all this
about what you doing and I was working
at the time as a full-time athlete
full-time mechanic and I mean door
security certain you know company as
well
so I basically said do you think you can
be the world Strongest Man leave me in
the eyes and tell me and I said yeah I
can [__] win the World's Strongest
Man he says well what's stopping you
I said this I said I can't I've got
mortgage to pay I've got bills to pay I
started to work full-time but me and or
company and I said I just haven't got
the time to recover and train I said I
can't afford my food and I thought you
know I can't afford to travel to
destinations to compete
which is ridiculous in itself so he
literally there and then shoot my hand
and said quit your [__] job I'm gonna
back you and that's how it started it's
always good when that happened yeah I
just started LA and he's basically like
you know obviously been his status he's
got lots of
business associates and and and
basically all chipped in and sort of
helped me out and it's been amazing that
this support from the local businesses
in Stoke has just been [__] Bob on
yeah you know they can all take it they
can all take a bit of pride in my tile
because they definitely helped me it's
nice when people from your hometown get
behind you like that yeah I wish I could
say I've had the same buckling to be
honest [__] channels one even [__]
followers on Twitter as a professional
asking questions I've got some great
questions and there's also I find quite
striking about the world Strongest Man
is one of the few competitions in the
world where there's nationalism but it
doesn't seem like nationalism which has
got that and that's the edge to me slow
sort of it's the odd is a bit of pride
about that you guys all carry Flags out
and there's an element of that but it's
not sort of it's not it's not easy out
do you know I mean yeah yes I mean
that's all I think because it is the
world Strongest Man they've just got to
separate this bar by country basically
and the way to do it you know and
obviously it's sold off to so many
countries having sold to some like
ninety countries the world Strongest Man
so to have you know obviously they have
the English with England representatives
to support England next to your name and
then on the sites are English TV is so
much easier end of the day it's all the
bow it's a money-making
competition like everything else like
the NFL like football it's all about
money you know
well frustrates me about will strongest
minders I feel like it's it's it's such
a good sport now and it's come so far
and people like you are bringing it into
the mainstream particularly but some of
the ways they put the content out there
still very 1970s like like the fact that
it isn't live is this point to me meant
all I got I'm like people want to watch
these guys these are they're not looked
upon is the big strong guys they're
athletes now people like yeah
especially because like gym life
generally is come on so far in the last
20 years people want to know what you're
doing and the training methods and all
of that I just think that they need to
make it live at some point as you feel a
little bit like that um yes and no I
mean the thing is it was so tough to get
it live because the will Strongest Man
file is spaced over two days and you
need two days you know you it's like
three or four hours between each event
and you need that [__] Recovery
Center so if you get if you're gonna
make it live then it almost makes it
impossible to the athletes to recover
you know because you want to if you're
gonna do a live show you've got to fit
it in two hours really haven't you
minimum at most I think what all wise
people are gonna get very bored yeah you
know watching blunt blunt blunt TV wise
to setting up north for events and stuff
you know I also think the best the best
way forward thought for the strongman is
the way they are doing it is making it
you know doing these shows editing them
down making them into a professional
show and sending them out to TV that way
if it was alive I just don't think it of
that potentially like you come from the
tomb or anything careful potentially
there if they could find a way where the
Lots could still have that rest and
still and then well here's my kids man
so why not run things like your
documentary in between the events
because if you if there's you know they
do there's a little sort of tweet
packages on people and you know we're
getting to know him yeah five minutes
that's all well and good but like if
they ran a documentary on each guy in
between each event maybe two
documentaries a little bit of social
media in between people finger back
talking to some of the guys camp you
like the jobs to admit why I saw
Charlize I mean what I am to understand
is if you sell it to TV it's more
lucrative than if you do it online and
that's that's the big issue right now
and if you sell it online you know we've
got 16 million musio there for a fight
that you can't monetize that in the same
way send that to English TV American
yeah
I just think strong ones that the other
way if they would be like the Olympics
you know you did staff with the the
heavy weights wants to have at least or
movant why and you then go to the middle
weights event one light weights about
one then back to the heavy weights event
to that kind of thing perhaps do that
but that I think that's a long way off
and ward
what the world pate of you will
Strongest Man yes the ward but do you
think they'd get the same amount of
money as the money they get off so
international countries it's my weekend
I very much doubt it
yeah come so can we go back to Europe
bring and then because I am fascinated
by the fact that yeah you were like
champion swimmer and all of that as well
what was it
what will your mom and dad like with you
growing up did they realize what they
had in their hands early on like yeah I
mean I'm the youngest of two brothers it
was free brother sorry so but you know
to all the brothers Alex and James and
we were little [__] bastards
we were horrendous you know looking back
now I don't how the [__] my mom and dad
got through it mom and dad were very
very good parents you know my dad worked
his ass off in a factory for thirty
years you know never home hardly ever
that the weekends you know he's a very
very drained mentally drained physically
drained man over the you know soaring
[__] hate life basically man was a
swimming teacher and she worked with
disabled children you know mentally and
physically and but basically that's
where my swimming career started was the
swimming my mom basically took me in a
pool at age two and that was it's way
more [__] drown and I swam and that's
how he started honestly that's how it
started by age five I was in a swimming
club swimming for Newcastle swimming
club and the two older brothers swum now
as well and that's where the competitive
started not not from the other swimmers
not from people my age but I'd have to
beat my older brothers
have to that's that's a sibling gravely
that's that's human nature isn't it you
know you want to be better you don't
want to be bad than you probably you
want to beat your brother it's tough you
know you put a you put a two pizzas on
the table backing it out quicker than
you go you know it's constant in it when
you're a child everything's everything's
a competition so that's where my
swimming came and you know it very
quickly everyone my age I was twice as
fast and that has moved not the group
and I swim with brothers and then you
know I'm starting so I could catch them
up and then by age ten surpassed them
and it's not right I'm better than those
two swimming now so what's next
that's be the best in the country so at
age ten I was literally training 17 to
20 hours a week in the water you know
before before school after school I'd
get up at 5:00 in the morning at cycled
down to the saleon baths do an hour and
a half session cycled school do a day at
school home food and then cycle back to
invest for another hour and off session
every [__] day you know I was driven
I was [__] driven I mean I was a as
11 when a woman affairs nationals you
know was the best river in the country
for me age broke British records you
know from from people that have been had
gone to the Olympics that's when I got
on the what they called the Olympic
potential squad so it's basically seen
as the the the Olympic feature of the
country so I was put into this squad
give it a bit of money you know my own
coach me a nutritionist give an extra
help with anything I wanted basically
and that that that to meat-free three
days in a row on the Nationals and I
said you know I smashed it a fare for
your British records I was destined to
be an Olympic champion
destined you know I was so driven and
then it just got ruined you know age 13
I just [__] hating it
don't know why they're not what happened
just was the monotony of the Surrey was
the
was this Olympic potential squad that
was on the you know they brought in
these Australian coaches and you've got
to do their way or no way I went from
swimming 15 hours a week to 20 hours a
week doing all different strokes you
know I was a freestyler and this guy
made me do best stroke backstroke
butterfly and I'm why I'm a freestyle or
why am i doing these things and I hated
it [__] hated it
and all the all Kings I had used to go
on these swimming camps for this Olympic
squad you know you go to where
Loughborough and Wonder in all sorts of
places and you'd spend two weeks you
know doing these camps literally [__]
sergeant drill up at five swim yoga eat
take your shift at this time stretch
again each take another [__] you know I
could have a piss then that kind of
thing you know and I just hated it and I
mean it's towards the end of one camp
and you saw the stupid system where you
know if you're late for a meeting you
get a black tick pretty free tips in you
were sent home
I'm like this isn't me I'm not I'm not
[__] destined for this [__] yeah so
you know I've got two black ticks I
think I think I got caught smoking and
one of those calories set the whole
[__] building fire alarm off as well
and and then it came you know I'll bill
sweetening once it wants to see you you
know that they had Australian coach I
said [__] it
so tell that fat can't come see me and
that was it you know I was on the squad
out that I thought got back to to Stoke
I'm like [__] out give up swimming
carried out on for a bit but I just
Wendell all me first-place trophies turn
to second thirds Force lost interest
15 years old I was expelled from high
school what you did loads of Fame mainly
involved in my deck
but loads of things yeah you know what
kids are like Anna flopping your dick
guy everywhere you can't a that kind of
thing funny I got expelled for the same
thing when I was eight
yeah yeah
yeah always gonna want better okay
nothing the last straw was the you know
there's a lot one lied he was absolutely
[__] deck in my yearbook bully beat
one of my mates up so it was snowing at
the time I'll never forget it and I said
right this is the plan we're going to
first snowball at the [__] leg chase
into the woods and I'll wait in the
woods and that's exactly what we did I
beat the living [__] out of that [__]
body couldn't take it like a man and the
police were involved so I just got
expelled so that was the end of school
career anyway who tooted which is the
best thing that ever happened to be
honest I got seven GCSEs a to be not
hate to see [__] me yeah so believe it
or not I was very very bright at school
I just chose not to [__] put it into
lessons you know I think it's mad when
you look at schools generally though
like for me personally when I'm sat in a
room for the kids like whenever I would
get more one-on-one time I would just
find it so much better but then that's
where I from 15 to basically my last
year-and-a-half a high score I had at
home cheated and I learned so much more
and that year and a half I went from
probably a D grade student to an a you
know B a B grade which is which is quite
phenomenal really and obviously when I
was 15 or whenever I was at school I
actually joined the gym and every day
you know everyone would get up and go to
school I'll get up and go to the gym so
that and that's where I walk
weightlifting started for me at 15 I'd
go in here bear weights and I sort start
training with a local power left
powerlifter bodybuilder and he took me
under his wing and that's that's what
you know we went from that so that's
like that's ideal and it went yeah I'm
getting with someone who knows what the
[__] they're doing because unfortunately
I get large messaging and all the time
asking should I do this should I do that
and you see lads in the gym and the
wrists are going and the [__] me mate
you're gonna kill yourself yeah it's
tough I just say from day
pretty lucky pretty lucky in the gym
because you know everyone in the gym had
the stigma of chest and biceps and that
was it you know the wooden train legs
back but because I trained with this
power but it was in his 40s you know on
a train with him every single day he
blow out doing like said eggs
you know the putting D likes know we're
doing likes so from day one I was forced
to train properly didn't let you skip
skip leg day which was probably the
foundation of everything real so you
didn't even have all the mistakes that a
lot kids will make you look probably not
really correct for yeah yeah you know
Australia with very little as he was he
hard on you as he tell you like you're
not do this it was very hard on me yeah
it was same as in his 40s he was a quiet
never hard not as well that's ideal look
the kind of guy you wouldn't even you
want to look lighting twice in a
nightclub
you know he was a [__] nasty bustin
and so yeah it was ideal at age 19 yeah
I just found I was the strongest guy in
the area probably the strongest guys
Staffordshire and I thought [__] it and
then interest on man contest and it 90
you know entered Blackburn Strongest Man
I think I came fifth out of like you
know about 20 guys I believe is that
that footage in the documentary way yeah
well she renounces many more feel it
yeah yeah and that's that almost looks
like that's just in a car parks on yes
that's the way strong - yeah no it's
it's literally a car park sport you know
it's growing well that that's the
foundation of the sport it's it's a
Circus Circus sport at the end of the
day it's an entertainment sport so yeah
I went from there really and that's
that's
believer or not are born England
Strongest Man when I was 21 I never
trained strongman I just did
bodybuilding I was wanting to get big
and Aleut good consider go and don't
body but the bill didn't grow I did well
then I just realize how much of a
[__] bunch of pricks bodybuilder very
quickly yeah you know they're just I
should have said that it's just not my
scene yeah bodybuilding is not my it's
very different
on stage to show off both ego-driven I
guess very very narcissist that's the
we're saying that your hero is it of
course Arnold Arnold was yeah I just
found bodybuilding at the time just just
just just
I suppose in all honesty I found it too
hard right to gain strength and live
good at the same time so I answer I
found strength easy and I found a
six-pack hard so I went for the strength
through strike on what or you were more
naturally fairly my naturally
predisposed toward strength I was a big
lad you know he really got a bear in
mind because of my swimming career I
swam until I was 16 so 16 years old
there was 16 stone and honest to god I
was probably eight to ten percent body
fat I was [__] and ripped yeah I was
you know I big for a 16 role that was
big and that's where I got the
foundation really you know that the
swimming I already had muscles
everywhere but one capacity you know
that's important you know minds off the
Scot off the scale you can't even
measure it yeah and also heart function
as well yeah because I ste found out
over the years that swimming is one of
the only sports that trains the aortic
valve on your heart so basically because
when you're swimming you're holding your
breath and it stretches and it
conditions it basically so I've never
had any heart problems over the year and
I've had many scans and whatever else
what I was thinking another thing that
you definitely seem to gain from swimmin
is the state of mind which i think is
one of the most important things you've
got yeah that that I'm gonna beat this
guy I'm going to beat this guy and I'm
going back the brothers in competing
with them that sort of condition you for
what you do all the time now
yeah and again I was very lucky my coach
when I was I think nine to thirteen nine
to fourteen something he was out he
trained Olympic Olympic champions you
know
he changed memo basically his athletes
have won gold medals at Olympics
so I had one of the best coaches in the
country at my local swimming pool you
got very lucky in many ways lucky in
many ways one thing I'm interested in is
when you talk about being a
five-year-old like you say like a rumor
being a five you're thinking right I'm
gonna beat him that winning mentality
that passionate drug that succeed it's
not just in you eyes that's something
you think you've developed through
experiences as well I don't know you
know they always say that for in
successful athletes like there's
something missing there is a dark hole
and I couldn't tell you what that dark
hole is but I'm always trying to fill
something you know there's there's
something that makes me want to drive on
and be successful probably to stop me
from getting depressed when you talk
about your dad early and how it was
obviously hard watching him do a job
that he obviously wasn't in love with
and he was drian and over the years like
me personally getting into youtube I
wanted to do some that made us happy and
I enjoyed and I'm guessing watching him
become more miserable than what he was
doing did that ever spare you want I
think I want to do something I'm in love
with so I don't have to I think so I
mean I mean my dad I sort of admired him
and felt sorry for him at the same time
because especially where we live it's to
get a good job it's just [__]
impossible and he was literally stuck in
a rut you know he was working as a
health and safety officer at chemical
plant for 25 years day and Dow and then
from the sounds of it the company didn't
appreciate him is doing the work of free
man and it was about three four years
ago he quit his job and it got to get
two people to replace him which says a
lot doesn't it you know they're really
working the [__] and just don't want
to be in that situation because enough
words I've been a mechanic I was back on
it for 10 years and hunt on heart nobody
can nobody can say they're happy working
for somebody else you can't be how can
you get up every day
nine-to-five take out four or five
hundred quid a week and the person
working force of with billions you know
I was working from all the dairies yeah
you know billion pound company and how
can you be happy you can't it's [__]
you can't be happy so and that I first
suppose my dream or one was to work for
myself I don't want to have a boss you
know I want to be my own boss and I'm
not very good with authority I really
aren't you know I'll get on the work you
know when it's what kind of Cal get on
will work but I just couldn't deal with
somebody
yeah little jumped a little [__] [__]
on you had to do basically you know I've
couldn't deal with it so many parallels
here yeah I speak like exactly like
you're saying right now all the time
gosh you don't picture I was saying be
your own boss I'm gonna say my hair
being told what I do do you know what I
mean but that's interesting cuz I
actually don't mind being told what to
do
alright but I I'll never rationalize
that it's about that person I because I
feel like what I find interesting a lot
of guests say I think I'm very well at
school never really enjoyed it and I was
completely opposite I got I'm fine at
school always enjoyed it just put my
head down and did what I was supposed to
I think school was probably made for
someone like me but understand why it's
not always made sure those other people
what I do find interesting about you is
character those you are quite open about
corny suffer narcissist
yeah which is is interesting because
there's as soon as a bad thing Niecy
knows instantly about Facebook and it
isn't it isn't because it's only a bad
thing if someone's a narcissist and they
don't know it
yeah that's but you know you get people
that yeah women they're literally
plaster makeup wear Prada drive a
Mercedes and [__] literally think
they are better than everyone else put
the nose of put people and I've seen it
and they're [__] horrible people but
I am narcissistic you know I bought in a
way where I don't think of better than
everybody and then anybody else but I
think I'm better than anybody else in
strongman and that's different that is a
different thing I'm not above anyone in
life yeah
you know even someone in jail I'm still
I'm still worth the same as they are
but in my shows like when his swimming I
used to walk around with me [__]
bollocks swinging like I was King Kong
you know I asked to think it was the
dog's bollocks to think it was
invincible and when I when I started
strong man exactly the same like you
said my first appearance on TV I had a
mohawk a beard screaming I just loved
that attention and I love to entertain
and I think that's my person it that's
that's that's all that is that
combination of awareness and yeah the
whole I think obviously it comes from
the Greek method that narcissus it was
like completely obsessed with their own
image and yeah hey and it almost
rejected people who said you're amazing
yeah yeah they thought the doctors and
sort of mob and I think that's why I'm
so when I see these negative comments in
the naysayer comments
that's the narcissist in me going [__]
you yeah you know yeah you're wrong I'm
gonna prove you [__] wrong and that
that's so it's in me and out what I'm
aware of it and I control it you know I
don't anyway yeah I Drive around in a
for [__] for groundcar you know I don't
kick the [__] about materialistic things
I'm not sure off in that respect I just
want to do well and entertain at the
same time and you've got to be a
narcissistic [__] to do that you've got
a Finch you've got one Muhammad Ali
Muhammad Ali is the most probably on the
most narcissistic men on the planet but
because he was that narcissistic I'm the
great he said he was the greatest before
it was the greatest yeah that's what
made him [__] famous and that was his
branding sucka the same with me that's
my branding then nobody thinks that he
was a narcissist now because he achieved
you can't when you achieve you can't
Paul Arnold a narcissist now because he
has been in the past but that narcissism
got him to where he is now yeah you
can't hold that against him you know
that arrogance turns to confidence do
you think there's also elements of that
that so for instead of people
depression and narcissism and sometimes
it can have that I don't wanna call it a
dark side I think that's so cliche but
it can have that side where it can also
lead you down if you're doing the truth
then you start feeling maybe if you know
cheap or maybe if you just feel that
something's gone wrong I think you in
your documentary again I don't wanna
give away the whole thing isn't worth
watching even they were speaking about
every subject you've got in it you speak
about the depression that you felt when
you knew your grandma was dying in
cancer and that took that was a
seven-year period that's a very long
time for someone to be depressed
yeah I mean but again I think that's
that's what my whole was depression you
know and I had to do something out to do
I had to have a goal to stop me sitting
in the house and potentially slit my
wrists yeah I had to have sight to be
active every single day and I think
that's that is my whole when in reality
is the only thing I could think of is
depression and stuff why I mean and the
family and you know get expelled from
school and falling out the swimming
coach and it's just all these things
with [__] Monica Lee depressing you
know and I every time these things
happen if I write [__] it what's the
next goal let's concentrate on that and
then I put all all me energy into that
and that depression would what would go
and do that me wrong enough I've had
some bad depression and that in the past
when I've what I've got I've lost my
ways I don't know where you know when I
got expelled from high school it was
[__] tough it's [__] hard man
because you're just thinking self
[__] [__] my life up here you know
15 years old I'm expelled from school
I'm gonna be end up in a [__] you
know some some Institute for [__]
idiots or whatever but the fact the
winner at that time in life is worrying
and I think it's the worry that makes
you depressed because as much as I was
good at school I also remember a lot of
adults I sort of got bit behind the
curtain because my dad was teacher
and they would talk you know about
people who are self-destructive and they
just write kids off yeah you think you
were one of those kids who is written
off by [__] yeah hundred percent yeah
how did that that must have felt pretty
[__] [__] was a very defining moment
in my life where I was an absolute
[__] class clown at school you know
but I love to make people laugh I was a
I think I was a funny guy and as toward
just before I was about expelled and it
was actually a substitute teacher that
put me in my place you know as a [__]
[__] for in the whole class and yeah and
he said I had to stay behind me so all
the class laughed and this guy give me
the biggest molecule in my life you know
he literally pushing me in the chest
then you [__] prick sort your [__]
out who do you think you are
and it's like what unity when y'all
decide I'm gonna be at the time you know
swimming that's how I'm gonna be an
Olympic swimmer [__] is that you [__]
idiot they said what you're gonna do if
that doesn't work work it you know be a
paper boy and I was like [__] it really
hit home and I was like [__] I am I'm
[__] up here and it was a while I
don't know a month later I was explained
you know two months later I was expelled
so it it [__] hit home but it was it
I think that that made a big change in
my life I was like [__] and that's where
they are don't you - enough main it made
a real go with me mayor exams dead well
and went from there really because it's
hard to ask this question without
assigning disparaging of your parents
but I'm not asking it in that way you
say they're great parents most people
most you know when you see a kids
expelled people go this is the parents
parent so what makes you say the
opposite of that cuz I'm not passing
judgment on them but there must be a
reason why they're good parents you know
I mean it's my personality I mean I've
got a son now I just come up to five and
he's got very severe ADHD can't keep
[__] still can't keep his mouth shut
and I think I was the same you know I I
had some sort of some sort of unique
autism
where I just couldn't keep still
couldn't keep my mouth shut and you know
and in abide by rules and and I think
that genuine that all the brothers and
they were fine you know they got in some
[__] you know of course it did but
nothing like I did nothing and that's
just I genuinely think I had some form
of very unique autism and my own little
world where you know people taste it
people get really weird traits you know
the do things and the have to be driven
and you know you have constantly on
something I think there's a different
leader I'm really in a hell of a lot
I've got a civic I mean everyone who
watches this reg you know that I'm
really in a lot you because a lot of the
things you're seeing about yourself I've
said about myself and that without
knowing it and I just feel like
sometimes people like like me and you
these types who have they need to have
something the tunnel there's a vision on
and they need a channel this otherwise
we see people every day who the lives
are [__] [__] tip and I sometimes
look at people I think if I have not
found YouTube or had not channeled all
of this in it that would be me like I
now know I came dangerously close to
like because that was just by chance I
ended up here and do you ever do you
ever think if they'd not found strong
man like what the [__] would have
happened to you sort of thing or if I
didn't ever have found strong man I'd
probably like my dad stock in a [__]
rott working a [__] job for good morning
but just you know working till you 65
missing all you you your kids and wife
and what actor to me you know that is if
people want to people are happy with
that then their [__] line who the
[__] wants to work on the 65 and night
to fight you know I mean that's a long
[__] Thailand chunky a life gone in it
my plan when I got into strongman was I
want to be retired by 30 that was my
plan all along didn't have pretty much
stuck to it
so I just yeah the strongman definitely
kept me going if I had never got into
strongman I bet your blog so cool and
we're done I was gonna say you two
almost quite lucky you were born in the
time when you were coupon eighty-eight
cents yeah yeah so you two are quite
lucky in the time you were born because
it was before the time when people go
that's ADHD or that kids got a learning
difficulty and instead they just got
these [__] difficult get rid of it
yeah whereas now when you say your son
is diagnosed specific ways even though I
know yeah but III Steiff I think he's
got some for ADHD of making even autism
he's very hard work at the minute but
he's you know he's still trying to
settle into school life and I can see so
much of me and him but there's there's a
few roots those kids go down having seen
because sometimes kids get told you've
got ADHD and then they go down that
almost the dark side of ADHD or if they
make an a bad identity out yeah I mean I
can't do anything in life yeah he's
almost lucky to have a dad like you or
go I'm exactly the same as you and this
is how we're gonna deal with it you know
I mean yeah yeah yes and that's exactly
it so I mean with my son now we're just
getting to that age where where I'm
gonna start getting into some sports you
know what everybody wants you know I'll
just get make sure he's got all the back
and do whatever the [__] you want
well Seaton obviously I've got a lot
more time on my hands now yeah a lot
more you know all those years basically
the first four years of his life I've
been missing and that's the God's honest
truth
and it's just ten five and I can make up
for it now you can guide him the tunnel
and so he's yapping on your back and but
this is the this is the this is the help
I never had
yeah but actually it is because I was
forced into my swimming with by my
parents your mum was a swimming teacher
yeah so I think that was luckily their
way of controlling me was get on with
you swimming how was how does your wife
obviously she's his mean Kara how does
she handle your son is a did
difficulty yeah it's difficult you know
he doesn't listen he does what he wants
you put in too bad and he literally stay
up till midnight just throwing his toys
around the room keep coming down one
food I want drink you know he's now he
hasn't gone bet too bad before 10
o'clock to this day yeah he's just so
active and I'll get up in the mornings
he's literally jumping around the room I
tell you there's not so what my wife's
doing well Jenny when she said she's a
fantastic mother
I got quite emotional when I watched you
in the documentary like when you were
like Oh getting upset about in that cuz
I don't know like I think it's probably
the most the first time you'll ever
watch a huge giant of a man getting that
emotional especially over a woman like
it's sort of it takes everyone back that
I think it would have changed a lot of
people's opinions about you as well
yeah it's we embarrassed about that
afterwards are we just like you know
this is me that's me put me over there
that's me sure it's just the way I am
it's you know like the family's
important founders very important
there's no put being a big be ignorant
ogre you know I'm Eddie all I'm swill
strong it's why I'm not my family like
mm-hmm
first and foremost both songs of the
earth yeah yeah because actually it was
a it was it's a touching moment but it
didn't feel disingenuous you do see a
lot of documentaries where people cry
and you feel a bit like they've gone or
drop this bit now you tell me you can
tell this that's a really
well-constructed documentary I'm going
to say how do you think your dad feels
when he hears you say he's been stuck in
a dead-end job or you know he wasn't the
guy that I wanted I know my dad very
well and he wouldn't he wouldn't take
that as an offence no but how do you how
do you think it'd be very close with you
I mean there's very touching moment
where he's at your event that you
organized and he's clearly as proud as
you are to be there on that day
is that the kind of relationship you
know yeah yeah I mean without at that
close you know we spend loads of time
together he comes all the strongman
shows it was very supportive well but
yeah well I mean regarding to he knows
he's been stuck in a dead-end job for 25
years yeah he said it himself
yeah you know and when he quit he quit
his job a few years back actually and
just from the sheer stress and strain of
it and the difference in him [__] it was
like a different person was a different
person went from being a you know a
really sort of miserable tired
middle-aged man to a man that was
enjoying life lately you know he started
doing agency work now and it's probably
ten times as much and works ten times
less so and he's so much more happier
it's so much more happy it's nice to see
because I've grown up with it with a guy
that is literally sacrificed his whole
life for me and my two brothers and my
mom so it's nice to see when you start
progressing through the way it lifts in
and you know you're getting into doing
your competitions and that what point
did you start game in that conference
because I feel like people who lift
regularly that there's a sort of a a
point where you just stop tripping the
bar a bit tighter you start really
knowing I can [__] push myself here
and take this further was that when you
were training with the other guy was
during that time or I mean the real
confidence came when I won the first few
cases on this man you know that that was
the sort of defining moment where [__]
you know I've just one UK strongest man
I'm the strongest man in the UK but then
it got knocked down when I went to will
strongly spent 2012 and you fought me I
went to now as UK Strongest Man and a
firm out folk feeling like a little
little girl genuine he's genuinely you
know you saw Brian Shaw your source of
genius you sort for and at the time I
was
[Music]
at the time so what is interesting
notice is when you first go into the
environment is that's what I mean says
how do you fit into that because again
it's a rueful affirmation of the
potential male when I went to the world
no it didn't feel the alpha male a teen
you must have turned up thinking you
were yeah [__] you I thought you're
gonna dominate yeah I was gonna make the
fine I'm gonna do good you know
mid-range but I got slaughtered I want
every couple of events you know I won
the Viking press in the squat you leave
but then on the you know the yo with the
Saturdays just laughs basically for 56
did you feel it the new kid at school a
bit like when they're just felt out of
place but you've got bear in mind to
this point the only strong my trainer in
a dorm was strongman contest and I'd
probably done ten contests at that point
I stopped training as a body bill that
I've got in my mind I'm not gonna start
training strongman events until I'm
super [__] mega strong but you know
build the basics to squat the bench the
deadlift until I've got them right up
there I'm not gonna start training
strong though and that's exactly why
Dead 2013 I was first reserved for the
world's so it just missed out the final
and that's when I started that's when I
thought [__] I can make this I can win
the world Strongest Man is when it came
back from there I start training
strongman
I joined strength Asylum the lakorn gym
now and you know I said I bought some
strong one get invested a bit the
morning why you know jokes your logs or
that kind of crap and at the stones and
got on but every day you know I've
trained legs and then I do yo I train
chest and then I do log
I trained back and then I do stones
every day I do training as it would
normally would and then I do event
training so I incorporated it did you
join that yeah it was exciting you know
I was excited the thing that kept me
going the most was seeing improvement
weekend we can't literally every week
I'd come in and do another app on you
know 200-kilo bench it every week I'd be
like seven reps next we could do a next
we could do nine and then I drop it to
220 and I'd was you know it's just
constant and they all loved it I love
the improvements one of the events that
you're most famous for now is the
deadlift was that just dear warden beast
like just naturally career that I was
but I was never the best at dead lifting
you know when it was I say I think 2014
my PB was 400 kilo at the star 2014 and
then they announced the world deadlift
champs and I thought to myself what the
[__] can I do to sort of when my you
know because at the mini I couldn't pull
400 kilo so I heavily researched dead
lifting techniques programs I did a lot
of stealing you know I studied and he
bolted and Betty Magnuson heavily
studied Brian shores technique and the
programs I basically wrote my own
programs out and stopped to them to a
tee maybe words just just for general
thinking I realized that the human body
can't recover from a deadlift this the
back end of ten days so if you're coming
in every week and dead lifting heavy
every seven days you never recovering so
that's when I got on the head right so
if I do a heavy deadlifts session I need
to do a weakest speed deadlift to help
me recover so one week when you do in
the heavy weights nice and slow
you train in the slow twitch fiber
and then the next week when you're doing
speed wraps you train in the fast twitch
fibers and that's when I realized you've
got two sets of fibers in your muscles
in all your muscles you've got a train
and both so I did a weaker speed in a
weaker heavy and I did that for six
months and my dad went up to four
hundred and sixty kilo in six months so
that that speed I'll see this the
acceleration off the floor yeah and then
and then when you try and that's the
hardest bit if you can snatch off the
floor and get it to bite you knee high
you've got it yeah [__] got it and
because I look at your technique quite a
bit because Benny's totally different
you here's a here's a nun to say [__]
you know that looks painful lightly and
I actually I think that that is one of
the main reasons why you've got five
hundred and he didn't as well as because
your technique is so much better than
his in my opinion you you see the
deadlift like like a small man who's
been blown up yeah do you know I mean
you've got perfect technique so that
makes complete sense how did you when
you did the the four six was at the four
six one really one yeah
I know you sort of covered that on the
documentary but what we didn't get to
see is you really the Diaz afterwards
and that what was it like when they sort
of taken that away from you it's very
dark very depressed you know here's a
massive climax to that show and
obviously pulling a world record and
then time it stretched it was tough you
know I nearly I made the thought to
myself [__] you now what's the point it
just felt so pointless after that but
that that week and appalled that
deadlift was the flicks which moments in
my career so I literally got back that
weekend and said to the wife well the
wife said to me actually if you can put
if you can do a world record deadlift
you can be the best in the world at
deadlift in then why the [__] aren't
you'd be the world's strongest man
you've just proved you the bestest
now go out and [__] when the world's
be the best apart it feels like Adrienne
and Romeo said you know what you're
[__] right you are right and it was
literally that so that was the sadly
than one day I never went back into work
I wrong in work that six months sick bay
[__] you more it was literally around
that time that I thought [__] I'm
gonna turn pro if you have to take loans
out and borrow money I'll do it but
luckily this was the time that I met my
manager and during that sick leave
period he promised me to sort me out and
that's when that's when it happened so
it was the it was the deadlift that
actually defined my my career you know
it was that if I'd have been given that
left mmm maybe all this never ever
happened and I wouldn't about the fire
in my belly it was the fact that had it
stripped thought wrongly [__] angry
so it's a very public it was a very
public thing to have our thousands of
people watching people there on the day
yeah yeah analyst team also your peers
yeah directly in front of you to the
sides hearing you want because there's
that camera angle from the side as well
when you're picking it up they're
actually cheering yeah well yeah yeah
there's a little bit like yeah what you
said about Europe's as well if I hadn't
if I'd won Europe's maybe I wouldn't
have pushed myself as hard as I said so
when that happened you didn't get that
500 can you tell us a little bit look
because that was in my opinion the most
watch weight lift of a nice hundreds of
millions in history there's not even
close everyone into the gym but long
ladies old men talking about any Hall
500 like what was that like so I think
was the year after that I did the 463
kilo of Europe's and I pulled it so
[__] easy
that I just decided down that I'm gonna
pull fire 1/2 kilo I know you know I
made it public as life I don't no one
wants to put the money up front I'll
[__] pull 500 kilo and that's pretty
much what happened you know praying
Dynamix put the money up and I [__]
went for it and I actually still train
for will Strongest Man but I put my
heart and soul into my deadlift sessions
and I put my heart and soul into the the
physio the recovery the stretching
everything everything was landing on
that one day that was a done it set me
up for life that 500 kilo dead it really
did
there in no other way and if we never
could because nobody can take that from
you and it in mine in my eyes in my mind
pulling that 500 kilo would would have
made me the strongest man in history
ever and that's why I wanted it and and
all the naysayers on the 500 was was the
worst I've ever had really I've never
I've never seen such negative beforehand
when you were trying to do it yeah I've
never seen such negativity lay over this
in the sport so where's it coming from
yeah Facebook general chitchat in the
gym you know yeah because I was very
open about it you know every week and I
can't wait to pull that far when to kill
off the ground and like press the world
away from me and all that big in my self
up so much you know the like I don't I
don't walk on this planet I spin the
planet beneath my feet but kind of [__]
yeah so yeah and just the backlash from
that was like that this guy hasn't got a
chance in [__] hell you know a lot
more me everybody every comment saw
black possibly 470 maybe 475 but no way
500 and every every single comment I
read out sighs [__] keep it coming
keep it coming and it really did fire me
it can't be so [__] angry that people
said it wasn't possible and I knew in
the back of my mind it was I knew his
every day
and Anu is a big risk to take but I
wanted that strongest one in history
status to rewind a little bit we skip
this step where you lift in front of our
nose for snicker and he's chairing yeah
that was the world sex more 6-4 6-2 -
yeah yeah you just finished s-- another
competition in America you have flew to
Australia the next day
wake up and me they give you a call and
say we've got the world record right
here come on break it basically ever
happened yeah so we're from Arnold's
America so did the Arnold's in Ohio
cause he didn't go how I wanted just
didn't I didn't have enough chance to
train for the event not making excuses
the Britain Strongest Man was a month
and after four yeah and I couldn't
change the Arnold's simple fact and you
have to train you can't lift someone 2
kilo yoke on your back without [__]
training for it but you were still
gutted by that way oh yeah yeah as I
wanted to [__] win the [__] you know
I go into every contest to Wed and if I
don't it's massively disappointed and
sends me in a massive depression yeah
so on the back of that I was asked to go
to Australia literally flew from America
to Australia three flights free flights
landed and then the organiser Tony
Doherty who was the first time the
Arnold's had ever conscious really you
know he wanted to impress Arnold so we
asked the strongman see what can we do
and and Collins up and yeah we'll get
someone to pull a world-record deadlift
and I think from memory serves right I
think he asked Brian before me
right at all honesty that's not yeah I
know what I said yeah I think Brian's to
saw said no [__] chance some thought
so he asked me and I was like [__] you
I'll try it I'll [__] go for it did
you know one I thought something was
gonna be there on the day yeah yeah that
was the point it was new is gonna be
there but the timing was just up in the
air so there was 11 a.m. on Sunday
morning you've got a poor war record
deadly so we went there we did
it we're doing the warmups doing the
left's and then it's like I mean it's
like he's running late and I might right
sorry guys I said I've got to do it now
or so it's not gonna happen so I just
got on with my left and just as the
strapped on to the bar Arnold [__]
came in on the corner I was so stoned
out I didn't even know he was there
did the left smashed it down and then
I'm in the celebration realized who the
[__] was stood there it was just it was
just [__] incredible
Missy shout me use me from the right I
didn't even know he was there honestly
it wasn't until I did the left dropped
it and so I'm doing the celebration
afterwards I'd aspire did you pull away
and you almost got the opposite way to
him yeah I was just gonna go celebrate
with the crowd exactly and smack
everyone in the face you see the look on
your face when you recognize him and you
start going towards in this like what do
I do now yeah it was incredible and it's
great because afterwards he interviews
and he says you had another ten in you
and you can see there's a light bulb in
your head bit goes I was a [__]
lovely moment of my life that was that's
moveable to no matter or before that
yeah for him to actually sort of look at
me and recognise me and see me as
someone he you know pay attention to me
which was [__] nice yeah really nice
because he is he's the biggest star on
the planet in my eyes and to blow away
your idol if they have God my you yeah
it's one of those moments where you're
like [__] out yeah I've looked up the
yummy whole life and now you're admiring
me that's how far I've come
yeah it was good it was nice but then
obviously this quite that's big number
500 is a massive number and doesn't big
distance from 416 that actually was one
of the on like the 500 because I wasn't
really frightened for you as a funnier
when he did for 463 I was like it's just
Eddie that's what he does or 500 minute
and you pull that bar and you did it
fast
yeah you put me that that speed work
that's definitely paid off because you
ripped it off the floor
but it's when the pepper was pissing on
his I find these for your [__] heads
- I was like yeah that is the most
frightening weight lift up ever see it
was like it was almost like one of those
snuff movies you know I got Jesus like
what's going on the 40th day showed
wasn't actually the the face that the
face they showed was from the 4-6-3 was
it for 65 the list before was on the 500
they couldn't show on TV because there
was actually there was so much more book
without my face and I went out my eyes
my ears my nose it was [__]
everywhere could you feel that at a time
no you're just absolutely a question I
was just focused on that lift got it to
the top and I just remember looking at
the crowd and then just wake you up on
the floor right and literally I are
kidding you a puddle of blood like the
size of it for TMNT pizza on the ground
I was just like [__] you know in and out
consciousness you know everyone so
everyone sent it I'd just get up and
[__] make out your art to the crowd
so I took every ounce of strength for me
to get up and do a little speech went
back and I just collapsed I was [__]
gone paramedics were on me blood
pressure was over 200 pulse was like 180
just everything was just [__] Garin
into shock basically and but no injuries
that's what I was expecting to rip my
[__] handstand office I mean and
nothing they ever saw about the next day
but nothing at all it was and since then
you've said you think you can go like
five hooded Plus yeah yeah genuinely I I
genuinely think I could active pulse off
for 550 550 550
without bleeding or
a lot of bloodshed he's like can we do
without all the lettuce but how I felt
on that day I perhaps could have pulled
550 maybe 520 would have been an
absolute [__] maximum Ida still it
wouldn't matter if it had been for 94 80
out of still a passed-out and whatever
ran away
it was the length I held it there where
a [__] myself thought yeah
but yeah that on the months afterwards I
just got this this sort of mega mega
drive when I was doing my dad live
sessions I've done 500 now what can I do
now and my sessions would discuss every
week's getting stronger and stronger and
stronger and then I'll see the world in
the final I pulled up all the next
amount of weight and I made it look so
[__] easy
in 2000 said this year's 17 and I
thought they asked me after was like
what's mean you could pull Ryan out as
I've got five four when the bard [__]
waybill and that's how I felt
I generally felt that [__] strong how
did the other strong men react once you
come round and they were talking but the
height for you or aware knew them
jealous or because you can say and again
it's all mixed emotions it's you know
everybody knows people came up and [__]
my hand an absolute [__] shock
because they just couldn't believe it
done it because they know what that's
like to try and live that way yeah
exactly and and you know I've spoke to
loads of people about it and even people
like Colin Bryce who organized the
[__] thing he said did you actually
think I was gonna pull it you know in
all honesty I didn't think you were and
that's yeah and that's the guy who big
got the promotion and he's the one who's
supposed to believe any more than any
won't even more than anyone know but I
don't think anyone believed was going to
do it deep down nobody thought it was
possible and that is quite humbling for
them to say that it is in a way won't
give me off yeah do you know what I mean
yeah
it's like what popular led you as the
[__] good Wang cry you oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's it's just what for
someone to say you've done you've done
why I never fall that was possible for
me and it's like you know the gritty for
me it's really you in that because
you're breaking down perception of what
is possible for a [__] human being to
do like yeah it's not just lifting with
like someone hitting a PB you're like
you're literally setting pb's for
Humanity and that's a you know people
say who else is capable of doing that
and there's people capable but do you
think anyone's gonna pull over 500 and
in my lifetime like at this point I
can't see it happening a German I can't
see her happy that don't think that's
gonna be broken for a while that's part
of it isn't it but well that's why I
wanted it yeah it was the magic number
it was the 500 yeah like you know they
were in an island before the show
because Brian Shaw wouldn't come over
because there was no there was no wait
in between 465 and 500 you know why
don't you just even the even the the
directors of the show had it we just put
you know a 475 or 480 in there just just
so just so you know it like a fail-safe
yeah cuz like no I was like [__] Brian
Shaw I was like if he didn't want to
come in to try the 500 what I'm not
having you sort of put weight in like
you put a weight in it's a 480 he pulls
that and then I fail the 500 where's the
fairness and that I said I want 500
Keela I want to I want to know how much
I can [__] do so then that's how it
went basically it was a reserve now in
Bali wanted to do it Bernie was fairly
confident he was gonna do it but I think
it was we had a training session three
or four weeks before but down Sadler's
gym and we were sort of winding each
other up and you know playing mind games
there was just one one moment where
Benny was it's very chirpy for the whole
session you're very happy and and
wherever and then we've gotten to the
Banton was like so idea how different
you're gonna feel when I pulled the file
inside I thought Benny cut the [__]
I said you know what I see in your eyes
right here right now what I was like I
see me pulling 500 kilos and he just had
to saw his body language change like as
I've got him yeah I'm so good at my own
games I've got the [__] now it's like
a fighting that many respects a lot like
yeah little stuff is that is the most is
the most important thing in these sort
of things and when I saw that reaction
of has that in itself made me gain more
confidence because I knew that he
believed I could do it and and Benny
said to me after he says I knew you were
gonna do that 500 I said I just didn't
know you're gonna do so [__] fast and
that in itself was [__] homeboy and
that was nice to hear it's also it's
interesting because I think the
perception of Britain or England before
that was very different in the world
Strongest Man wasn't it it was sort of
like you guys are the you were the
nearly Rams you know well done your Ma's
over that building on the football
thanks but the Vikings are here now do
you know what I mean and now you're the
one so well no I'm serious and it's like
and you're redefining the way that
people see Britain essentially as a
nation because they're you're leading
the way rather than something like what
they're doing it's not I might do the
same yeah yeah well I mean that I mean
the tile hasn't been in the in the UK
for 24 years
yeah and that's a long time it's at one
time not toilet island you know and and
I think I genuinely believe that once
that's added Christmas any of January
1st that every [__] is gonna want to be
a strong man yeah you watch the gems
fill up with people lifting lugs and and
out the stones there'll be a big demand
and it's like the rugby when the Bremen
won the Rugby World Cup everyone all the
sudden wanted to use and it would be it
boosted the sport people are gonna want
a piece of you yeah so I mean we'll have
to wait and see but I I think
I've just brought the sport back to life
for the UK yeah
one thing that is unbelievable for me me
it's the fact that you hit this school
and you just you said I'm gonna do more
I'm going to keep on going what else can
I do now that's their main that you've
guys I think that's what makes you
different all these are because
genetically you don't strike I mean just
start extractives [__] insane but
what I mean is that you look at the
other lads and you'd maybe say oh maybe
like I should be stronger than you in
theory or OPR you've got so much more
determination than them it seems so
anyway yeah it's thing is with any sport
hard work always beats guess he always
beats talent always you know you get out
at like four he's six foot ten he's
probably a natural 25 stone we have I
even [__] trying you know right actor
but you know you put me in and together
you put side by side and it just seems
you know but for the eye he loops
stronger than I am but you know it's
it's that hard work and dedication I've
made sure that's not the case
I made sure on the strongest and let
that prove that will Strongest Man you
know this there was no there was no
stone unturned with me nothing nothing I
mean for for in previous years made
excuses they dumped in what film work
and sacrifice their sacrifice that this
year he had no excuses because he said
he said if I ever finish sight and I was
exactly the same I turned out film work
I turned down appearances lost thousands
hundreds of thousands of pounds can be
nice you think it may take them up in
the future yeah now but but all that
morning all that fame you know I could I
could it possibly could have done what
Ford's done but I've got the will
Strongest Man tile now and to me that's
way more important and all those film
roles their appearances will be repaid
ten four
for that one title so it was worth
making all those sacrifices so in
between I think you came third and then
win and we'll Strongest Man yeah did
that year just go just perfectly apply
[__] perfect yeah
no accidents no injuries I said I come
back from 2016 and I invested in the
hyperbaric chamber that was a big
difference you know what and do you feel
different yeah yeah I mean a hyperbaric
chamber is vowing to be honest Google it
you know I don't hire to describe it's
useful diver basically a diamond still
there we get oh so so but the basic you
know and I spoke to a professor in
America who actually uses this on
athletes yeah so it's basically a
chamber that you get into and it's
pressurized now a normal chamber you see
on TV with the depressurize it to put
less oxygen in there she produced more
red blood cells this is the opposite
yeah
so you pressurize it I was pressurizing
it 227 psi which is just under two
atmospheric bars atmospheric pressures
so it's basically I've been 50 and 20
meters under under under water and deep
sea and with that pressure I was then
force feeding an oxygen pure Honda is
95% pure oxygen for a mouthpiece right
and all that pressure so everything's
open all those I'm like a snorkel
mouthpiece in my mouth yeah and there's
breathing oxygen from it and it's been
sucked out as well so it's in and out
and I basically why slice them watch
them in the chamber breathing this pure
oxygen all the pressures about 25 psi
pressures forcing the oxygen into the
muscles where it wouldn't normally get
to so all those little you know
capillaries and arteries and wherever
it's get into those areas
hence oxidizing the muscle and repairing
one hour in the chamber is the same as
having 12 hours out yeah so if you're
doing an hour every single day in the
chain
you're getting three and a half days
extra recovery on everybody else and
that's exactly what I was doing so I was
getting another friedhof days recovery
on ovary over a flea does it feel good
it's not nice right
I'll be honest you know it's like it's
cost of phobic you know I'm not cost a
fair bit but when you're in a tank on
your own
I was literally doing it at 12 o'clock
at night you know getting a tank and
there's no locks on the door because the
pressure seals the door so if you panic
and want to get out you've got to
release the pressure and you can't
release the pressure too fast you get
the phone because you got the bends you
know you could literally blow your
eardrums out and dangerous you know and
I made this kit with with an engineer
I've built it myself so it wasn't you
know it's not exactly medically passed
yes a so it's too [__] dangerous it
was but I was willing to take the risk
you know I read all the harlot horror
stories of people dying in these
chambers you know don't get in a bit too
far and and also the because because
yeah yeah inhaling oxygen and although I
had it the you know the carbon dioxide
and the excess oxygen sucked back out
there's a good chance that that was
getting into the chamber and if it
oxidizes the chamber if you create a
little spark bang and I'm not kidding
you you could blow up the whole [__]
Street yeah it's that it's that
dangerous so you know I had to wear it
to the ground and also have so careful
but it was a big risk just a weird
feeling you'd come out and feel a bit
lightheaded but then you wake up the
next morning it'd be like you'd be like
about a week off yeah yeah be pretty
good you can tell the difference in the
recovery doctor sure the the extent
you're willing to go otters yeah oh [__]
yeah that is nothing foolish yeah well I
say and and I can take a loan out to buy
that thing it was [__] expensive you
know and stuff like the physio that's
what I'm gonna come back for the world's
2016 I went out on the physio
was doing you know over 200 quid a week
in physio the food bill went up to 250
quid a week what wasn't like an average
deal like food was
everyone's like I've had a lot of
Twitter monk for what is the Easton's of
so air be instances where it's at alarms
at 6:00 a.m. get up have a liter protein
shake with bananas coconut oil knots
you know protein powder about 1,500
calories I'd go back to bed I'd get up
at say half eight that have a fun with
full English breakfast loads of sausage
bacon loaded good fats well you know
loads of coconut oils I'd have beef
jerky and I've toast and I've loads of
fruit nut honestly huge breakfast
probably two and a half hours of
calories just for breakfast a litre of
cranberry juice as with 500 calories an
electric ravages 11:00 a.m. it be a you
know 100 gram of cashew nuts dinnertime
it be swagged by you know steak chicken
pastures rice big portions pretty 400
gummies but meat and about half kilo
carbs put in would be half family
cheesecake then that that's like 2,000
calories in itself yeah behind the back
too bad
yeah the morning would be spent doing
physio and stretching I don't get back
to bed after dinner had to have a couple
hours Kip cuz I acted unneeded it for
the recovery and then I get up about 3
o'clock and I'll eat again it you know
I'd have a couple of tuna sandwiches
that are flapjacks lines of fruit and
I'll eat that on the journey to the gym
so I go to the gym on a full stomach
because I trained for four hours I need
to eat you know any three a lot can you
know you conditioned yourself because I
like the normally eat like I don't know
an hour before course you have to train
on a full stomach
otherwise you some that got no energy
are so yeah it'd be a four-hour training
session during that four-hour training
session there'd be two hours of cram two
weeks is of crumby juice with called
powder so that's a thousand calories
each with the car power their compound
it tastes good no but its its necessity
you know so there's two files of
calories just in cram be juice
towards the end of the session and I've
you know 3/4 towards the end of a
session I would oh no sorry halfway
through Musashi
Ross take literally pieces of raw steak
just get him in natural aminos natural
protein under the next baby this is
hardcore but there's nothing better than
a piece of raw steak when you're
training because it's it's all the
aminos the creatine's are all in there
but Tony's ex isn't it this is a story
three-quarter towards the end of a
session ID then beat you know start
having a praying shaken that'd be a
liter of basically Guernsey milk units
of cream basically with protein powder
that be 1,500 calories after training to
be a liter of coconut water to replenish
the lack of I hear that stuff to the
shrink you sweat
yeah that'd be but to the health spa
where I go to and I'd stretch for an
hour
I'd do my hot cold treatments for an
hour and then I come home and I BT can
that be spikeball Cory the over half of
the family cheesecake and then I go am a
hyperbaric chamber for an hour
and that'd be that'd be 11 o'clock that
saying it's all about half 12 and then
I'd go to bed with protein bars and you
know and that was there me it was just a
constant that was 24/7 and I get up and
Pete that every [__] day you guys
have your own a fridge yeah but a big
American freely exactly yeah it's always
full of food I think the people have
achieved the most in their life
usually a member just like an artist or
something like that but people who go on
to do great things the routine seems so
key like like followed Dorian yet in the
bodybuilding game he's a big speaker for
that and just generally you've just
conditioned your body it just being a
machine like you don't even it's not
really you as it at that point
no it's an officer let's get on to the
dangers of it you know it was [__]
risky mm-hmm
I mean I'm a peak I think it Europe
Strongest Man this year I was thirty and
a half stone what do you know about 29
right yeah so yeah and for me that I
feel but it was a dark place yeah you
can't sleep you can't walk far you can't
put your socks on
he's liver and kidney I was having blood
test my liver and kidney markers were on
the brink blood was like sludge because
you just I just could you just can't get
you all the crap was putting in my body
yeah you know it was it so fast was it
hard to it because obviously static
strength tends to be where your
strongest book and I know you've come a
long way and the other events but it's
the 30 and a half storm but running
around what the [__] man was saying and
lately say it was hard man and then
nothing was ten days before you're up
strongest man I overdosed on as
magnesium there was overdosed on
magnesium no potassium and I overdosed
on potassium 10 days before Europe
Strongest Man and basically I told an
ambulance out and [__] I mean Michael
really about heart palpitations skipping
beats and it was it was to the point
where so I was in bad when it happened
and mihari was about 140 beats per
minute and I [__] something's not
arrived here so I went downstairs and I
got the message come down with me just
to watch over me and then the poor
Thomas had dropped drop into like 130
110 100 90 80 and on my Alistair
somebody's all right ear with horrid
drop to 30 beats per minute and I felt
dead lightheaded and I thought you know
I thought it's gonna keel over as I've
ridden the ambulance ambulance come on
the heart rate went back up to like you
know what back up to 130 140 they came
out dead ECG
the basically said you're not having a
heart attack but all we can see is your
potassium levels are through the roof
and I was like can you really tell that
from an ECG yeah
you tell your potassium levels will out
off the scale and then I clicked it's
because I was sweating so much for on
the lead up to York because I was so
happy I was drinking so much coconut
water potassium tablets salt tablets
footmen and I basically just I overdosed
on potassium and it nearly [__]
nearly dead me and basically for that we
that ten days leading into Europe's I
had to go on it you know basically a
potassium free diet and I was I was
[__] bad it made me really ill and
that was that was be leading up to
Europe's and I was luckily just on the
day I was like you know me and the
doctor like you just about well enough
to compete you know he's [__] Skinner
Matisse again what people don't see on
there don't see their polish program yes
because I think at the same time when I
see you lifting me I know you've got the
stuff I mean shoulders whatever you're
lifting you think of yourself as a like
tsunami you know twelve stone lifting
map and being like well I could easily
walk that distance like you saying it's
tricky to what long distances for you
guys yeah Pleasant no I was it [__] yeah
and you know I family days out were just
a no no yeah you couldn't even go Kevin
just think of getting a golf cart and
just sort of okay mister all around one
yes
but yeah I couldn't go on walks with the
dog or anything y'all see the like Alton
Towers and that was just had the
question yeah that kind of stuff it was
just just at the [__] dark place
visions of these are Alton Towers I'll
[__] me its partner for me a guy who's
fitting you in that [__] harness
the rides yes oh yeah it was just more
for the kids when it comes to like your
health and now you're like very driven
and brief blog and to a degree you've
had you've got to block that out as well
because you want to get this weight off
the floor but equally and that's a
different sport but there are
weightlifting in the training yeah rich
Piana has just died Dallas McCarver I
know you'll know I think you've probably
met rich of you biani rich Piana yeah
what is it all the conventions any of
the lads have like have you ever seen
anything where lots of pasta we like
because I know there was in your
documentary yeah I was allowed on the
floor all these fights all I to have a
heart attack in front of me and I
watched him yeah yeah resuscitated which
was very hard to watch more fouls are
hot too you know and it just shows the
dangers of the sport but the thing is
with me and I say in the documentary
many time if you don't see me on that
number one spot
no real strong you smite I have a die
trying or a doctor told me to stop and
believe me a dr. Tophet stop many a time
hmm
many time a blood nutritionist told me
to start my own doctor told me to start
and then the the real big one was the
ten days before europe's went out that
[__] episode and you know all the
paramedics like you is no way you can
[__] you should be am bad for a month
from this you know it's really really
bad on the body and i went you know i
just thought to myself icon that I've
got six weeks till the World's Strongest
Man at that point I said [__] it if a
diet dies and that was my attitude I was
like I'm no way am I giving up I said it
was six weeks if a diet died and I
there's that but in my head that was me
like whether I warned it came sack in
third whatever that was new ASCO and as
much as I respect that attitude if there
was there a bit of you that you ever
felt guilt you towards you like you're
sown and yeah of course but then there
was also the other side of me that was
like if it didn't go for that
chaton and in when it there how could I
look in the mirror every day and see a
successful man and be proud of myself
and then be and be a role model for my
kids I couldn't do that
and that's why that's probably that's
what spurred me on more than anything is
the fort of letting down the children
you know I would however take the risk
it's the good old saying you know you
could spend you could spend 70 years as
a sheep or 50 years living as a lion and
which would you rather I'd rather do the
50 years living as a lion and that's
that's why to the risks so home in
January can see like the events exactly
what happened but how did you find that
year the final year started off it was
the events were quite suited to me but
there were some events in there that
were [__] [__] you know I think my
foot the first event I came fifth on and
I'll see what it was but then you know
and then I picked it off you know well
yeah it was all I can say is it was a
tough [__] bow really tough battle
and there were some points where I
fought [__] I've lost this and over then
there was some points where I was like
[__] are my walks in the stars are
aligned and you know what has happened
it just everything my perfect in reality
even though I didn't win every event
everything my perfect can you remember
the exact moment when you knew you'd win
it yeah yeah okay I can't talk about
that look you'll see you soon obviously
and I think I just say it to camera you
know I knew when I'd won it a new one up
on it and it wasn't wasn't the last
event when I knew it I would just watch
what you're like after competition
because obviously you're in a
relationship you know does your wife
have to leave you alone for a little
while
are you silly so before competitions I
was like a caged lion yeah you know you
couldn't you if you interrupted my
schedule if you made me miss a meal or a
training session or a physio session you
were [__] getting your head ripped
off and
so it was women wife if she you know if
the littlest thing was out of place if
if she forgot the cabbage on a mere
[__] cabbage up the wall yeah but
that you just get because you get so
worked up towards events because there's
so much pressure on you after the events
it's a its eyes it's depression right
it's all a after it don't matter if you
win or lose is depression because you've
had a massive climax up to this event
you've put on air and then the next day
it's like after the after the the
firemen to kill a deadlift the next day
I was at my son's birthday party I had
like 50 people around the house and
nobody gave a [__] yeah so I mean
there's I all the family on keys are on
aunties uncles friends and nobody give a
[__] in it's like yeah if one or two
people are well doing that but you just
get on with your life don't you and
that's what's that's what's so that's
what soul I depressing about it like
you've just done something amazing and
you've got to go back to your [__]
nine-to-five wife minutes live Fox the
point yeah do you think that when you do
I mean I know you said when I win will
so I'm gonna hand it up you're still
competing in the UK but are you is that
you've done with the world's never say
never for this year you see in not this
year no I'm not saying anything I never
say never
mhm no but yeah I think when you do
eventually have to retire that might be
difficult for you dragon you know
honestly mate I think it'd be very easy
for me really yeah
even after the way you saying because I
just choose another sport and I'd crack
on
I'd say that's fun is that a new no no I
mean by choosing over sport I'd crack on
a Sat goal and I'd crack on
but there's one thing I do want to do
when I retire is lose a [__] on a way
back a [__] yeah I want to look good I'm
sick of people calling me a fat ones
uh-huh yeah it's it does get to me
yeah it does get too messy a lot you
know you just you might be you see all
the time and you when people share your
videos oh yeah it's impressive
- aye but you've got a we've got to be
the world Strongest Man yeah and all
these idiots like oh you know I'd rather
statics over over performance and my
book but I've got the aesthetics it's
just underneath all this you wait til I
retire man and I will I will [__]
shred up and I will with the bollocks
yeah that's a plan of mine I want to do
some sort of transformation from a fear
to stone monster - like a 24 stone or
percent body fat [__] freak yeah and
I'll enjoy it and that'll probably be
one of our goals but people I think
that's just them because they know not
even in my wildest dreams could they
achieve what you have done there's
always going to be something that I
think that's what that is just general
trolling yeah Facebook people just love
to put other people down I don't get it
oh I don't get why someone would go onto
someone's facebook page and comment
something negative I would never do that
in a million years I would never go on
someone's page and go I always got a
[__] one knows or there are small
death cause it's [__] fat [__] what
what I just don't get that it really
trolls really get to you there exist in
this yeah I hate the actual things they
say but their existence in the first
place is you know what I mean is that
their their presence online
yeah why go online just to troll people
it's just that to me is a very jealous
envious disturbed little [__] creep
yeah and the Facebook is full of them I
know my needs but I just don't get it
yeah I just don't get it why why why be
why my crush that's what else is like
get on with your own Conor McGregor says
winners focus on winning lose us focus
on winners and as that's similar that's
it yeah and that's what I mean all this
may say is stuff you know that most of
my trials you know you see I mean
the windmill Strongest Man and there
might of people that say you'll never
win for Bill strongest want you to see
too fat you're too slow but I might just
beat forward a [__] car walk at your
strongest man last week but I'm still
slow what ever may III just ban him now
yeah and I give a [__] but it was those
people that spur me on anyway you're
fueled by emotion of notice that yeah
massively love that yeah massive it's
good I think one thing that we've had in
the recent podcasts there unfortunately
a fellow we had on his his mother was
the first victim of the Yorkshire Ripper
PSO cliff all right and he we sort of
talked about his life and one thing that
came across for me is this not really
what happens to you in life it's how you
use that and what what you're using is
there negativity is just straight off
petrol yeah generally and there's
nothing what if somebody says you can't
do something there's nothing more
satisfying than going out and do it
mm-hmm nothing more satisfying we've got
some questions from your funds for the
sick first one has he ever shut himself
away listen it wasn't exactly actually
the first competition I went to watch
you is was a kid said and I think that
was why you pulled out actually first
event with yeok yeah it was I bet the
Yoko and and you said my hero next one's
a bit easier what can you bench well you
ever do one rep max I don't know I have
done a 300 kilo bench [__] raw raw as
well I think in competition I've done a
280 no 285 then I was with a [__] tricep
at the time Jesus so I didn't one
capable of well I think if I put my mind
heart and soul to it I could get for the
world record bench but who gives you
[__] powerless it's one of those it's
fully those that mentioned people put so
much into a place it's nothing compared
nobody gives a [__] you tell me who owns
the world record at squat who knows me
exactly gives a [__] who's the real
strongest man Eddie all the worst injury
of suffered during your competitive the
word the the world's 2016 I detached the
ligaments on my middle finger completely
gone so that hand is literally rendered
useless now so I mean it's luckily you
know in the next year so a tire anyway
but that any grip events I've [__]
absolutely [__] you I can't can't can't
grip anything you're right-handed I'm
right-handed yeah but obviously frames
and yeah you know farmers walks and
stuff you need to unknown yeah there's
just no strength yeah someone's asking
about your thoughts and thought I know
you've you've already spoken about what
happened have you seen them since then
and squared it away or is it just like
just left so it's water under the bridge
I'm sure he feels bad about what's
what's been and done you know I've got
nothing against for I don't I don't
dislike him you know it's just nothing
against them I don't think he's got
anything against me to be honest it's
just crack on with your life for you
know my crack on mine it sounds a little
bit like you're when you finish the no
you finish essentially you reach the
peak you're not going to go back every
years or go watch other people there are
certain people who have stick around the
sport and commentate or you're not
you're not into that yeah if commentates
you know 100 percent be there I'd enjoy
that can't be there in support and and
obviously you know commenting on the TV
for the English fans would be great
seems like a question as well let you
study other people's techniques I'm good
breaking that sort of thing down yeah
that's my job yeah you know you've got a
study in value a everything and strong
month yeah everything can you even
describe how intense the pressure is on
your body when you pulled 500 kilograms
to describe it
jeez well imagine someone strapping 250
kilo to each hand and making you stun
that for two seconds and imagine how
much strain that would put on your body
if I in fact go into a gym what 500 kilo
on a rock yeah and if you can lift it a
[__] centimeter away from the rock
I'll come and suck your balls
because you won't be able to do that
will give you some idea about hard it
was to do two kilo and the pressure
Wow who would you least like the faith
out of strongman out of all the lads out
of strong out of all this from a strong
male hassles only one who you'd be like
he's the last person over that Lord one
I have a scrap with I've really thought
about that probably the least person
wanna fire wood before it goes from his
sheer size and athleticism helps you to
be a little bit smaller in the sense
that is it smaller guys can know I've
been the bigger you are me you'd only
get Tyson Fury yeah six foot nine six
foot ten just his reach and his size ins
natural size and strength just gives you
such a massive advantage and that and
and that's why I'm one about hard work
always beats talent yeah but when
talents like freakishly [__] stupid
one box so you've who you've met
recently I see pitch over you were
nonetheless you were what was it like
having a chat with him me yeah AJ AJ is
a nice guy yeah he's gonna one-on-one
one got a punch by I used to sound what
the [__] means those that screwed on
he's gonna go a long way he's yeah I
think he's gonna be the the greatest
boxer in history who's gonna be in the
next of Muhammad Ali
wow that's massive I know you you've
done a few button like much as yourself
and that's on YouTube
yeah not nothing serious to a charity
stop yeah really
and I do I do keep fit with boxing
nowadays is I've quite you know every
week I do boxing just to keep fit mm-hmm
he's stupid enough to step into a ring
be surprised yeah yeah I I'm not any any
beef for about 10 years I don't think
you mentioned you on the doors and that
dude were you actually on the doors you
saw or did you just talk I was initially
yeah then I also set me on business and
any any stories from that always a
pretty play and soon yeah there's plenty
mate but you can't talk about over
myself many a time yeah yeah well when
what I notice on you is when you're a
big lad they never fight fair there's
always something else I mean I've been
pretty yeah I've never I've never been
really started on money that's about 24
stone nobody looked up twice and and to
be honest I don't know looking for
trouble you know I don't give a [__] is
the artist
that's not my person it everyone wants
to fight crack on [__] off but I'll say
how comes everyone's got an angry side
you know I have boy malade a few times
especially in this last four or five
years nothing's ever come of it come to
fisticuffs really yeah one thing a
friend told me that when they seen you
air one of the conventions where you do
all the meet and greets and ice you've
got quite a lot of attention from the
ladies meet the women apparently like
you how's it ever like being in any
compromising situation of a women have
just thrown themselves at you a bit
obviously I'm a married man I don't
before quite difficult I have to be
quite you know sensitive about that kind
of stuff but yeah you'd be surprised
there are some proper strong strong
fangirls out there they're on the alpha
male thing Lisa when I walk into a bar
you can always tweak this is that one
girl who's a big that's the thing that
I've seen the girls at the gym that just
just they're just magnetized with the
alpha males and you can spot them a mile
away it's easier yeah even these spots
them for is no that's great
Oh apparently someone said I don't have
a question but just let him know he's
done stop proud top rail fan and alright
which moment was better when in the
world Strongest Man or break in the 500
[__] me when in the world's where in the
world's meant the most but we both the
bow flight sort of supplement each other
because the I wanted the 500 kilo to
prove I was the strongest man in history
but your hot tub that will strong is my
tile to solidify it I feel like I was
lot of things from a business point of
view as well as I feel like the 500 is
it help grow your your fame so much yeah
where is the world Strongest Man
wouldn't have done that but now you've
got you've backed it up you've got some
of approval and you've got that moment
that's why there's that it's the
solidification of each other together no
just give it
I genuinely think I'm the strongest -
ever lived I do think that but there's
no one that can deadlift more or ban you
know in general squatting that the
overall strength far advanced ever much
me you have any more questions me one
last question for you mate
how would you like to be remembered I
would like to be remembered as the man
who mates from one great again in the UK
I would like to be remembered as the
legend
Eddie Hall the strongest one that ever
lived you've been absolute legend
frankly yes thank you very much if
you've enjoyed this I'll leave the links
all of any stuff in the description
below you can go and follow an
documentaries about with what off yeah
definitely check that out a lot of
documentaries for people who come on
this show some of them are absolute dog
[__] some of this one was genuinely good
and you get there some tingling moments
in there
you're also releasing a book me yeah I
am it's mm-hmm Eddie Scott's called
strong man mhm Eddie the Beast hole my
story it's released October the 18th you
can pre-order it now on Amazon I'll put
the link for that in the description
below so if you want to buy it the link
will be down there like the video thanks
for watching and subscribe and we'll see
you there